[Music]  now I understand a fan this dis chat  just happened yesterday but a fan sent  you a photograph it's pretty sweet yeah  a few days ago a woman named Carol  pitcher and Tony put this she sent this  to my Twitter thing and said it does do  you think this looks this Martin  brothers salt glazed stoneware face jug  looks like Andy Richter and then I  clicked on it and I think it does look  let's check it out maybe we can do a  side-by-side here that's incredible  it's like it's like me let's get the  other way  [Applause]  it's like and it was made it like 1900  this is this is proof that you've lived  before this is proof it and it sold for  like 11 grand so that's saying something  to that was kind of nasty it's exactly  what I know it's eerie scary